Fans go crazy for a good superhero movie.
For years, characters and stories from the
pages of Marvel, DC, Dark Horse, Image and
many more comic book companies have been gracing
the big screen.The genre is so unique and
varied that it can include moments of amazing
action, side-splitting hilarity, raw sexiness,
endless references to other superheroes and
much, much more - and that results in viewers
keeping a very close eye on the movies within
it.In turn, that can result in a lot of pausing.
Whether it's to marvel at something spectacular,
bask in the beauty of a particular character,
or spot a fun Easter egg, fans are constantly
revelling in certain moments in superhero
movies - and that's what this video is all
about.
Here are the ten most paused scenes in popular
superhero movies.
The Train Scene in Spider-Man 2
We begin our list with a funny entry.
2004's Spider-Man 2 remains one of the most
faithful and outright best comic book movies
to date.
Tobey Maguire shone in his best performance
as the titular hero, while Alfred Molina gave
one of the best villain performances of all
time in a superhero movie - and it's a scene
involving them both that we're referring to
here.Molina's Doctor Octopus had sabotaged
the controls of a train, leaving it unable
to break and Spider-Man to save the passengers.
Using his webbing and all of his strength,
Spidey saved the day - but the strained faces
Tobey Maguire was making were hilarious and
people loved pausing on them to have a good
laugh.
Naked Mystique in X-Men: The Last Stand
Prior to Jennifer Lawrence taking over the
role in the new X-Men movie timeline, the
equally sexy Rebecca Romijn played Mystique
in the franchise.
She looked incredible in the the blue make-up
that created the character's look - but it's
a scene without said make-up that is one of
the most paused in superhero movie history.In
2006's X-Men: The Last Stand, Romijn's Mystique
is injected with the mutant "cure", resulting
in her blue skin disappearing.
This left the character looking completely
human - and completely naked.
Viewers around the world looked on in awe
as Romijn laid on the ground in her birthday
suit - and they paused en masse to get a better
look.
Captain America's Shield in Iron Man
These days, seeing Captain America's shield
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe is no big
deal - Captain America had his first solo
movie five years ago and Chris Evans has become
a prominent part of the franchise as the super
soldier since then - but back in 2008 he hadn't
even been mentioned.That changed in Iron Man,
when a partially completed replica of the
shield was seen in Tony Stark's laboratory,
resulting in lots of pausing on the part of
the viewer.
It should also be noted that Captain America
could be seen under the ice in a deleted scene
in The Incredible Hulk later that year - something
a lot of people have pressed pause on since
it was made public.
"Thor" in The Incredible Hulk
Prior to Captain America's first appearance
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe, the next
Avenger to follow Iron Man and the Hulk into
the franchise was Thor in his 2011 solo movie.
This resulting in some retrospective pausing
of a scene in 2008's The Incredible Hulk,
when viewers thought they saw Thor making
a brief cameo.It came in the scene when the
Hulk and Betty Ross are in a cave and there's
a thunderstorm going on.
Viewers thought the storm was caused by the
God of Thunder's arrival on Earth and swore
blind that they saw him fall to the ground
in the background.
Of course, they turned out to be wrong, but
a lot of pausing went on when people believed
they had seen him.
Nite Owl and Silk Spectre in Watchmen
As with the audiences of any movie genre,
comic book movie viewers love a good sex scene
- and they were treated to one of the more
revealing examples in comic book movie history
in 2009's Watchmen.
The scene in question was a sex scene between
Patrick Wilson's Daniel Dreiberg AKA Nite
Owl II and Malin Åkerman's Laurie Juspeczyk
AKA Silk Spectre II.It happens on board Dreiberg's
Owlship and Åkerman's breasts were completely
exposed for the scene.
Of course, this resulted in a hell of a lot
of pause buttons being pressed around the
world, as viewers honed in for a better look.
Scarlett Johansson's Face in The Avengers
It's always comforting to find out that even
the most beautiful people can be caught off
guard looking less than attractive, so when
that happened to the gorgeous Scarlett Johansson
in 2012's The Avengers, a lot of people were
eager to see - especially her fellow females!Johansson's
Black Widow was caught looking a lot... well...
uglier than usual in the scene in which she
commandeered a Chitauri aircraft.
As she went to cut a cord holding a Chitauri
henchman in place, she made a face that only
her mother could love!
It's a scene that has been paused many times
- and been used in countless memes - ever
since it was first seen.
The Collector's Collection in Guardians of
the Galaxy
Superhero movie fans love a good Easter egg
and, these days, spend just as much time looking
for them as they do enjoying the plot of the
movie - and the most Easter egg-rich scene
in comic book movie history came in 2014's
Guardians of the Galaxy.The scene we're referring
to is, of course, the one in The Collector's
museum on Knowhere.
Benicio del Toro's character owned a lot of
interesting species and items - and eagle-eyed
viewers loved spotting them, which resulted
in a lot of pausing.
The likes of Howard the Duck, Adam Warlock's
cocoon, a Dark Elf and the slug creatures
from Slither are just some of the things that
could be seen in there.
The Avengers Jump Into Action in Avengers:
Age of Ultron
At the start of 2015's Avengers: Age of Ultron,
there was an epic scene in which the six original
members of the titular team storm Baron Strucker's
HYDRA base to retrieve the scepter that was
previously wielded by Loki in the first Avengers
movie.As the team cut through Strucker's forces
like a hot knife through butter, there's one
epic moment in which they all jump into shot
together - and it's a shot that prompted the
use of millions of pause buttons around the
world.
Iron Man is flying, Captain America is on
a motorcyle and Thor, Hawkeye, Black Widow
and Hulk are all leaping - it looks awesome.
"The Wasp" in Ant-Man
In 2015's Ant-Man, viewers learned that Janet
van Dyne - the original Wasp - disappeared
into the subatomic quantum realm while disabling
a Soviet nuclear missile many years before
the events of the movie.At the end of the
movie, Paul Rudd's Scott Lang also had to
go subatomic to defeat Corey Stoll's Yellowjacket
- and viewers noticed something very interesting
while he was in the quantum realm.
It was an outline that looked very much like
the original Wasp - prompting lots of viewers
to hit pause to make their own assumptions
about whether or not it was really her.
Harley Quinn Getting Dressed in Suicide Squad
2016's Suicide Squad received very mixed reviews
from critics and fans alike - but one thing
everyone can agree on is that Margot Robbie
looked absolutely incredible.
With that in mind, this particular entry in
our most-paused moments list should come as
no surprise.It's the scene in which Harley
gets changed into her costume and a large
group of men watch on in awe.
The camera pans all the way up her body and
just about catches a glimpse of her bra as
she pulls her top down over her torso.
Men around the world - and indeed some women
- paused that scene over and over and over
and over again.
Thanks for watching our video about the ten
most paused scenes in popular superhero movies.
Did you enjoy this video?
Which other moments do you always pause when
you watch your favourite superhero offerings?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.